in
counter-strike players aren't just
trying to lift comically sized
checks and trophies they're looking to
write themselves
into history there are legends who will
be remembered for their incredible aim
chance in this but forget the end lack
of detection he's gonna go aggressive
oh my god those that will be celebrated
for their inhuman ability to prevail
against the odds just perfecto and
simple he needs a multi-kill
first found twist aggressing they have
to double peak he's getting his shot
he's hitting another one
simple oh simple that's unbelievable
what in his name number one in the game
he's done it again and there are
others who will be immortalized for
single acts of heroism
here he comes once again the first base
is a trend he's going to hit the ground
there is cold
that's jumping double for cold what is
it going on right now
how does he do this corner save
luminosity with your play
unthinkable scenes there on the b
apartments but
unfortunately for alexi alu yali despite
taking a number of those boxes
his legacy might be resigned to a
different
type of fate you see on the one hand alu
is a god he's an ultra talented opera
capable of performing awe inspiring
miracles
but it's just aloo all alone 30 seconds
in a one-on-four
he's got to find simple first then he
does sees the shoulder right off the bat
drops down tries to catch someone off
guard
doesn't happen he knows zeus is in the
open though he needed that flick he
needs to get the follow up but he does
one on two and they're out in the open
and he's got it he's got a fourth
now we can get the bomb planted in olu
it's his turn to go nuts
36 hp the fight begins
four kills the molotov goes in and there
it is
incredible work from alu and the ace
when they needed
the most but on the other hand aloo is
programmed to self-destruct he's
well a bot but uh or that no that's not
a stick but
it's a headshot it's a glock and it's on
first oh
oh he's bamboozled himself and the
shocking unpredictability of his play
has not only made him one of the most
divisive figures in csgo's history but
it's also become one of the community's
biggest memes
so can alu ever shake the joke that's
become inseparable from his career
or is this would-be god forever destined
to be held
captive by his inner bot here we go is
it bought or is it gone
well the crowd loves them no matter what
if you've been following counter strike
at all for the past
decade chances are you've heard of olu
he's the most
famous and successful finnish
counter-strike player of all time
known for his unusual sense of humor
he's no [ __ ] given attitude how
important is it for you
as a team uh performing at this sort of
lev thanks very much harley
his irresistible urge to ask important
questions
are there threadables only for the
commercials or can you actually
drink them no you can actually you can
drink them
and most notably for being one of the
most erratic performers the game has
ever seen aloo now he may be having a
good game but this one is a little bit
too much to ask for holds onto the m4
falls back
and saves it for a rainy day
hello the hunter has become
the hunted no
oh my goodness oh no harlow
not like this after establishing himself
as an
obvious talent with ants and mousesports
alu really began to make his name in cs
go when he joined nip in 2015.
and at first the finnish opera showed
everyone that he
was capable of the divine flips i'd have
a lurker towards the be
sight but he's not going to come into
play just yet i need to open things up
here defensive shot onto simple
and now they're probably gonna know
what's going on another great shot there
from ali dropping blade
gonna go up the top for another one
takes down bondic and
four frags in quick succession from allu
oh
and ali's gonna pull off the ace down
goes the bomb and the cts are coming
from the same direction they want to
double peak it seems
let's see ali gonna get the first nap
onto berry only sand in remaining with
32 hp
they're opposite sides of the fight
they're gonna jump up and always going
to annihilate him that aloo gator is
here and he's in the death roll
that could actually give up a lot of the
rounds but freiburg goes down aloo now
close trying to no scope
gets mark club with a head shot and
against cypher focus
what is going on this is unreal now
bondic is still in a great position to
try and deal with this round here
it's going to be taking a shot there and
allo is going to get it 1v3 clutch what
a god
even though olu was proving himself
capable of turning a game on its head
every now and then that wasn't a good
thing
and nip starting to build a bit more
momentum bondic might get caught no
man's land here
because he's pushing out with no cover
and al who's just hiding behind the rock
he'll spot him does he see
him does he see him four by three four
by three there's no way he didn't see
him on the right side
no way they walk right past each other
what kind of circus is this there is no
way to know that's the bomb down on
fryeburg as well
and bondic gonna run for more if he gets
one more kill here this will be the most
unreal timing of the whole tournament
28 seconds left they try and run in here
but nip actually backing off and that's
aloe going down bonding
flanking two players just what the hell
is going on
he's gonna be on it and get right he's
hearing it but he's not getting the
angle right it's being diffused in the
background and there it is
the round for flip side just couldn't do
anything and that's going to be match
and map point here
flip side a single round away from
taking out nip
i mean how do you not see that unless
he's like adjusting something meanwhile
while he was hiding behind the rock
that's insane
and it was during this period that the
cs community really began to
recognize that allu was actually two
players
wrapped in one while he was a
world-beating god
most of the time he also demonstrated
that he could occasionally be a
blundering bot
if they look toward this catwalk aloof's
face patient and hits a shot it could
have been all over right there he misses
it now they know
and they'll try and push him further
back with utilities but he's gonna face
this he dodges the flash how does he
miss that shot as well
that's two big misses and aloo will be
lamenting it and while bot aloo did make
a few
unfortunate appearances that year 2015
was
overall the year of god aloo eventually
alu ditched his pajamas in favor of a
second stint with ants but even god aloo
couldn't help the all finnish rosters
shine on the world stage
and by the latter half of 2016 he was
recruited to be a part of
phase clan through his whole career he's
been a very reliable opera that's a key
detail so i think that's a very good
for a team like this where you're going
to have a lot of ups and downs and
phases you're going to have star players
who might be raging or upset or tilted
or choking
or whatever else and you just want a
reliable guy who's slotting in here
to bring up the overall day-to-day level
but joining one of the most
inconsistent cs orgs of all time only
ended up making the meme
stronger with both god aloo and bot aloo
routinely making appearances
oh oh that's glorious isn't it james
what do envy do it does he go
[Laughter]
nope oh my goodness
ally please oh man he's gonna pick his
fight he chooses ramp he finds flamie
now there's so many those three players
he could find none of them from az
bomb's gonna go down absolutely no
contest towards that
ali watching the rotate what ellie
these look on as well like some of those
actually look like they were on i don't
know it's aggressive
one way to do it oh that's why
that'll work and the auto sniper at that
wall kerrigan has mentioned that what a
shot out
because he continues to get aggressive
smoke will be deployed as well that's to
be a thorn in that side and another
great shot from allu
it's the fourth as well looking for the
ace
delivers in round number 15. what an
amazing performance in the first half
from them
in time allu's unreliable form became
such a community talking point that it
even developed into a
joke within his own team i'm playing
beyond train
is that good does it hurt sometimes
yeah when there's like five smokes three
molo
four flashes it's good luck i have i
have nico as back up though so it's good
burger yeah
not like yellow sometimes whoa now
eventually faze and olu's inconsistency
would be
no laughing matter and that came to a
head with their disastrous
last place finish at the pgl major that
has to be
highest expectation and worst outcome
that i've seen in recent memory as a
major
after being replaced by guardian alu
moved to optic
but yet again his god bought complex
continued to be a
thorn in his side that's a shame but
we will see aloo knowing where naf
pushes out from as he's going to be able
to line up that shot taking him down
nice and early in the round
giving optic the advantage to start it
off once again
i feel like al is really hitting his
stride in terms of consistency
these last maybe like two weeks
because that was like one of the things
that people would knock him for so like
that
kind of like jekyll and heights
just as you say that yeah right like
this is like perfect timing right
because people would call him bot
aloo or goddamn he's really hitting his
consistency and
dies the falling i still stand by what i
said
olu's career had become defined by a
meme that he couldn't erase
every bit of progress he appeared to
make was negated by his inability to
control
which version of himself was going to
show up
but that's when he heard it the sound of
the motherland
calling to him again
aleski alu holly hails from his journey
spent in international teams a man may
leave
finland but finland never leaves a man
once again he picks up the green rifle
this time not for money or fame but to
smite
all opposition in the name of ensladus
that's right for the third time in his
career aloo joined
ants but this revamped version of the
org
was very different than the one he'd
known before
the team was now made up of some of the
best and brightest young talent finnish
cs had ever produced
and alu had been brought in specifically
as a veteran voice
to help them reach their potential from
an outsider's perspective
aloo might have been a gamble but for
ants
an organization steeped in a rich meme
tradition
both the god and the bot were a perfect
fit
so aloo i've got to ask you this and i
want to kind of tell you right away the
mvp for this tournament
by astro gaming is sergey and i i have
to get some words for you about this
young player
he is a monster yeah
all right she's just waiting ever so
slightly walks at hello
is that looking at his near enough to
shut them down
at the approach rather but on the site
as he plays from catwalk head shows
that's a
very impressive shot stuck in spawn they
know he's there as well i think he'd be
better off saving the awp we'll see
he fancies it making his way up slowly
make some noise now oh my goodness he's
giving him a chance
oh what the hell just happened there
unreal
now despite ensa's penchant for not
taking themselves too seriously
over the course of 2018 they proved
themselves to be
far from a joke i think this cements
them in our mind
a justified invitation for 2019 it's
just around the corner for this team
say it with me folks it's easy for
n but ensa's profile would
truly be elevated at the katowice major
in 2019
where aloo and his ragtag finnish outfit
put their mark
on the event is this the end for liquid
in kadavitza aloo 32 kills to his name's
gonna add another one
and here's the quadfire aloe with two
this could be all she wrote for liquid
20 seconds left and ally chipped in for
a third
and a fourth of diamond they pulled off
the upset
time's ticking away you don't want to be
that player but always finding that
confidence oh
[Applause]
and although the finns fell short
against astralis in the grand finals
the event in some ways felt like a
victory france
not only did it help them win over the
hearts of cs go fans
and confirm themselves as a serious
threat to the game's elite
but for alu it was redemption on the
biggest stage with all of his doubters
watching
he showed that he was still capable of
being a god
on his day and this is what shut liquid
down towards the later stages of mirage
of that opening map and it's going to
start him off well here
allu going for the follow-up but he's
got it it was sergey but then again
we said it always the anchor and he
certainly will hold fast now
his gun's the runner that sears the
whole ship as he gets yet more
it's a one-round game he arrives just in
the nick of time
sneak up though they're gonna stay on
top of the bomb zips has not moved an
inch
so perfect so precise
zalu gets it the second off works they
held it off but just wanted to work back
in the ramp he couldn't do it 14-9
i'd be lying to you if i said that
bought aloo had been eternally
vanquished
in fact since the major he's made his
fair share of cameo appearances
another all is going to try to take the
place of his teammates
and he was all out of good shots he used
them all last round seems like every
round lately
made in brazil has gotten the opening
kill on that very round oh no
and they're used to jump ball and
finding allu um
in the meantime has decided to work his
way all the way around to get to the
back of heaven
i don't know if there's somebody here
that can defend this bomb plan he has to
hope and pray
that it's going to be a stick but uh or
that not that's not a stick but it look
at this a head shot
it's a glock and it's on first oh
he's bamboozled himself look as
frustrating as alu's god-to-bot
ratio might be for his fans there's one
thing that's for certain
his unpredictable habit of producing the
spectacular what
and the disastrous i'll be on one hp
running his way towards the bomb side
and he kills himself what a way
to end that 16-7 we'll always make him
worthy of our attention when he's on the
server regardless of which version of
him decides to show up
no one's going to kill aloo here look at
them no one's hunting for this kill
samia's not going for it now he's on the
knife as well pistol out
oh he's not going to go for it
sorry sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry no
no it's a guy i'll just wait for that
okay okay
it's it's very good it's it's like an it
is like a truly elegant meme
it's really well done it's really well
done yeah no it's [ __ ] sick
like the music video is like funny like
the song is really funny but like it's
goofy
that video is not goofy like that video
is genuinely badass we've been trying
this
since 11. oh
my god all right [ __ ] you
yeah all right well i got this jank ass
[ __ ]
up now jesus christ just my [ __ ]
light just tilted over
all right oh let me stop the recording
that's gonna be funny as hell